what we're encouraging people to do is a
really radical departure from what
they're currently doing but that's to
adopt a whole plant food diet it's free
of the salt oil and sugar and what
you're left with is things like fruits
and vegetables raw or cooked minimally
processed grains beans nuts and seeds
but you don't have the meat fish Val
eggs dairy products oil salt sugar and
highly processed fractionated foods that
make up the majority of the people's
diet in industrialized Society why do
some people get an influenza or a covid
or an infectious disease and you know
they recover they survive they have
minimal consequences other people it's
devastating or deadly well if you look
at the risk factors associated with what
makes people vulnerable to these
diseases it's the same obesity and
diabetes and high blood pressure and all
the consequences of dietary excess these
are reversible and preventable
conditions people don't have to have
these conditions and even if they have
them they can largely reverse them by
taking responsibility to control what
they put in their mouth